given the restriction that the sum of
the first number and twice the second
number is 24 so let's look at that so
the first number we'll call ax twice the
second number the second and we're going
to call Y the sum of those adds up to 24
now we want to maximize the product and
the product you can think of that as x
times y we're trying to find the maximum
product when you multiply the two
numbers together but you can see the
issue here we've got two variables and
what we want to do is we want to combine
those two equations into one equation
with one variable so the way we're going
to do that is we're going to solve for y
in terms of X I'm going to subtract X
from both sides of the equation and I'm
going to divide everything by 2 so if I
do that you can see that I'm getting y
equals negative 1/2 X plus 12 now since
we know what y equals let's go ahead and
put that in place of Y in the product
equation and we have P equals x times
negative 1/2 X plus 12 and we can
distribute the ax to both of these so
that gives us negative 1/2 x squared
plus 12x equals the product now the
first thing you'll notice is that the a
value is negative and this is a
quadratic equation x squared equation
which tells us that the parabola is
opening down like this okay so there's
the product here's the ax value and
we're trying to find out what x value
gives us some maximum product so you can
see that occurs at the vertex now
there's a couple different ways to do
this problem one way to do it is to go
ahead and find the vertex any which way
you want you for example you could use
the formula x equals negative B over 2a
if you use that technique it would be
the opposite of 12 over 2 times negative
1/2 which let's see that would be
negative 1 negative 12 divided by
negative 1 gives us positive 12 so you
can see when X is 12 that's going to
give us the maximum product or you could
do the completing the square technique
and put it into vertex form that's
another way to do it so let me see if I
can show you that it would be negative
1/2 and we've got x squared let's see
minus 24x plus blank half of negative 24
is negative 12 negative 12 squared is
144 but if we're adding 144 that's
actually negative 1/2 times 144 which is
negative 72 to counterbalance that I'm
going to
at 72 and so you can see that if we
factor this now you can see that the
vertex is at 12 comma 72 so you can see
here this is 12 comma 72 which means the
product is 72 when X is 12 now if we
want to find that second number Y what
you can do is you can go back to this
original equation that we wrote okay or
the variation of it right here and go
ahead and substitute 12 and for X so if
we do that we get y equals a negative
1/2 times 12 plus 12 which gives us
negative 6 plus 12 which means that y
equals 6 so our two numbers are going to
be 12 and sick